et au bout d'un moment
découvrez que maylis
on la retrouve pas au real et 10 par
mois elle est plus là et après ça
s'enchaîne la gendarmerie les militaires
l'hélicoptère
les enquêteurs la criminelle enfin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que le pen vaccinale vient d'être
votée par le parlement l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi le
conseil constitutionnel se prononcera ce
vendredi en faveur ou non de son
adoption définitive
les manifestants sont invités à brûler
symboliquement dépasse sanitaires
alors au liban parce que tu as brûle et
on passe non match alors je vais le
faire symboliquement
pas parce que première chose cloche
obligé de faire des passes et là je vous
lance un message moi je vous lance un
message ça c'est la flamme de la liberté
j'espère qu'on va retrouver nos libertés
pour nous et nos enfants voyez c'est
symbolique mais moi je le fais devant
vous monsieur qui grandit de
mois je vais vous expliquer une chose je
veux pas rentrer dans une loi je veux
pas rentrer dans un système où bernard
pour une autre cote au café père m'a
demandé ma pièce d'identité vous rendez
compte qu'il va se passer la grille un
mec mais si tu sors j'ai donné
tous des menteurs le patinage va vous
emmener à donner une pièce d'identité
avec la première commande et c'est ça
moi je te laisser finir si on habite je
veux pas que le maître sache comment je
m'appelle où j'habite quand est-ce que
je suis née cannes national et quand tu
faisais un chat que tu fais est
apaisante sa
distraction d'après-vous déconner mais
les mecs vous rendez compte que vous
vous faites désactivé moi je suis pour
le vaccin vous mais je suis pas contre
le passage suis contre eux passent à
l'étape pas oxame désactiver à distance
certes y'a un mec qui va dire tu arrivé
de voir un resto je te désactive allez
hop la presse tu désactive quoi d'autre
après ceux qui tuent des actifs
limite
les chérit le 31 janvier s'ouvrir un des
projets les plus attendus de l'année
celui de borna le land est accusé de
meurtre de la petite maelys c'est en
août 2017 cette affaire a traumatisé
bien entendu toute la france le maire de
la petite maelys a donc eu lieu dans la
nuit du 26 au 27 août 2017 lors d'un
mariage connait tous la sphère séverine
vous étiez au mariage ce soir là oui
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce
soir là donc vous êtes un mariage tout
se passe bien c'est oui tout se passe
bien c'est tout le monde s'amuse
on est content de se retrouver
voilà et au bout d'un moment
découvrez que maylis
on la retrouve pas au real est ce par
quoi elle est plus là elle n'est plus là
au début où vous dites bon elle a dû
aller jouer bas au début on la cherche
pas ce que tu vois là c'est aller
quelque part elle joue
où elle est allée se reposer ou
donc on cherche qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans les heures qui ont suivi les
minutes les heures
c'est un cauchemar cauchemar c'est un
cauchemar on cherche on la trouve pas
et après ça s'enchaîne la gendarmerie
les militaires l'hélicoptère
les enquêteurs la criminelle enfin
c'est comme dans un film c'est sa
surface et à quel moment aucun moment
même vous qui étiez au mariage vous êtes
dit
se passe quelque chose de grave
assez rapidement quand même assez
rapidement vraiment vous êtes dit c'est
bizarre qu'on l'a pas du tout ça c'est
bizarre c'est pas dans ses habitudes et
puis elle connaissait pas l'endroit
musée nuit c'était à 3 heures du matin
elle connaissait pas beaucoup de monde
parce que l les voyez pas souvent donc
ce n'était pas normal qu'on ne trouve
pas
dans les jours qui ont suivi la
disparition de manif vous aviez encore
de l'espoir où
très vite vous étiez très inquiète avec
votre famille v10 gardait l'espoir mais
au fond nous ah oui on savait qu'il y
avait peu de chance pas les heures sont
comptées
ces tubes au moment où ça a commencé à
se demander où était ma vie avec ma
soeur avec votre soeur elle vous a dit
on la cherche et on a cherché sous les
tables on a cherché d'abord les camions
frigo on a tout ouvert les poubelles
le parking
le petit coin où les enfants pouvaient
se reposer partout on allait demander
forcément à tous les autres enfants
voilà si la après ils les autres enfin
beaucoup dorment eps qu'il était trois
heures que la maman 2010 avait justement
croisé le landais sur le parking
quelques minutes après qu'il ait tué sa
fille
c'est juste incroyable regarder
jennifer se souvient avoir cherché
l'homme qui avait montré à sa fille les
photos de ces chiens sur son téléphone
quand j'ai trouvé mes revenus du parking
et il était tout seul et j'ai demandé
s'il avait vu malice qu'il m'avait dit
comme si il était blasé un peu non j'ai
pas vu non je les ai pas vus puis c'est
tout je me suis dit bon train de faire
des idées je n'ai pas écouté mon
intuition votre intuition me disais
quand elle me disait que ne s'était pas
que malisse était petit talus
le long des il avait déjà été condamné à
20 ans de prison en mai dernier pour le
meurtre d'arthur noyer
m est ce que vous pensez qu'il livrera
ses secrets pendant le procès où vous
n'en avez
nous avait aucun espoir là dessus
c'est vrai que les assises il ya une
grande part à l'oralité et puis c'est
vrai aussi que ces assises seront
particulièrement longue là le plan
d'audiences très clairement ces trois
semaines trois semaines d'assises on
verra on verra mais encore une fois dans
ce dossier là on a la chance d'avoir un
dossier d'instruction qui fait
vingt-trois mille pages avec de
multiples éléments sur les faits mais
également sur la personnalité narbonne
le landais voilà et je pense que le
moment venu la cour d'assises pour a
apprécié la solidité de ce dossier
qui très clairement à mon sens c'est un
dossier qui a été très très bien
instruits par les trois juges
d'instruction pour travailler sur ce
dossier
[Musique]
des manches ou j'te par effacer et la
plus belle des études parmi les autres
je vois que toi si tu te sens à 10 mois
et près de moi les projecteurs sur toi
c'est vous que tu me donnes en est la
plus belle mademoiselle comment j'aurais
fait pas de port du casque est chaud
le contrôle du tout comment gâcher
mascis tâche de reconnaître moi je suis
comme beige bleu
ok c'est le
passé mais ya que toi je peux confier je
sais je
quand je reste
ça a fait clic petit confort
[Musique]
toujours j'ai pas suite
très bien passé chez carat quand tu
joues à accomplir
[Applaudissements]
on
va revenir sur les extraits hier de deux
documentaires qui était complètement
nous dit franchement bravo mabanckou
alain mabanckou formidable oui on va
commencer par vous montrer l'un des
extraits du documentaire qui a le plus
tourné sur les raisons on y voit des
enfants choisir entre deux poupées
jamais la poupée la moins jolie
[Musique]
la noire est ce que j'aime pas trop les
voir
pourquoi
c'est ce que tous les infos les colis
sont blanches et moi quand je serai
grand je mettrais que la crème pour
devenir blanche ferrer c'est
incroyable de voir ça oui mais savait
d'ailleurs laetitia et l'eau et qui
était à côté de moi a très bien répondu
à cette question
c'est à dire que ses enfants alors ça
c'est une connerie je l'expérience qu'on
montre déjà depuis quelques temps il est
déjà un des états unis et moi je peux je
comprends et je comprends je n'excuse
pas mais je comprends ce qui s'est passé
un peu ce qui se passe dans la tête de
ces enfants là les temps ont changé mais
tu en trouves des barbie noire va y en
avait pas et comme elle a bien répondu
laetitia
cela culture on ne te fais pas aimé
quand il était chez elle au congo et
même aux antilles on ne pouvait pas
aimer votre culture maintenant les stops
les temps ont changé heureusement que
j'avais un vrai rôle à ce que je
représentais pas juste yannick je
représente aussi
tous les blacks qui joue pas au tennis
c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai
demandée ça m'est tombé dessus voilà
j'avais envie de montrer que c'était que
j'allais être le premier à le faire et
avec le chinois arrivent à gagner que
c'était quelque chose qui nous donner la
force en fait on lui reproche d'avoir
utilisé la terminologie blacks
c'est d'avoir fait saga africa nous
approcher de la branche santé saga fou
car le gars il est d'origine africaine
sa saga foccacia gène qui
lui savait déjà que le tyran la du roi
proche c'est maintenant où la parole est
libérée conclu roy point effectivement
de dessin dans
l'histoire et qui devrait prochainement
terre il a montré des cas isolés de
racisme et là on peut se demander si la
france est raciste et qu'on a vu qu'il
avait un raciste parfois de la société
on a vu que sa mutation travail voyage
oui c'était à peine laetitia louette et
donc laetitia louette canton à mon nom
en fait pour annoncer une réunion à
laquelle j'ai participé car rien voilà
je m'appelle pas aminata pas de nom de
famille et a pas du tout de lien avec la
diversité et ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand on voit arriver avec ma
collaboratrice
qui est une femme blonde est celle qu'on
appelle laetitia watts vermine je
vouvoyais regarder ça oui et j'ai une
amie qui a vécu ça aussi à la bnp oui
chargé de clientèle effectivement clé
une passation de pouvoir
puis quelqu'un qui arrive qu'ils étaient
convoqués pour rencontrer sa nouvelle
société et que tu agressés à la ferme
blanche bonjour madame
en france à la bnp donc c'est une chose
qui coince si oui c'est même encore
maintenant c'est vous dire savez ces
nouveaux outils la plupart des cadres
semblent
les séries je voulais qu'on voie ce qui
s'il fallait pas nous payer il n'y avait
pas trop incognito un patron incognito
va rappeler le principe c'est un patron
qui seront dans son entreprise grimés
pour ne pas que les salariés le
malheureux connaissent et dans
l'entreprise d'informatique suivi ce
jour là on a découvert un jeune homme
nommé joris qui est devenu la star des
réseaux sociaux quand il a déconseillé
un client d'acheter un ordinateur
assez fabrique ses propres ps pc je
voudrai jamais c'est une bagarre c'est
une vraie merde
c'est vraiment
pourtant il ya nom de l'entreprise
dessus
j'ai pas peur de dire que voilà je vous
le rendrai pas et je le vendrais pas ici
non d'accord
je crois même patron qui se rase la tête
justement regardez il c'est vrai
regardez là là là alors au school là le
patron c'est la première fois qu'ils se
rase la tête complètement ah oui c'est
plus moi c'est un peu le look des
appareils sont pas nés
pour la ressemblance c'est à vous de
juger en tout cas pour la première fois
dans l'émission un patron a osé se faire
la boule à zéro c'est vrai qu'on les
reconnaît pas donc là ça fait ça fait
vraiment plaisir on se dit on se moque
pas de nous parce que les gants les
qu'on les reconnaît vraiment pas et le
petit joris pour se rattraper de sa
bouche de sa boulette parce que ce
patron a été vraiment exceptionnellement
gentil et il était apprécié de tous les
internautes parce que vraiment on a vu
sa bienveillance avec les salariés il
était vraiment génial eh bien il a
ouvert la chaîne youtube pour le magasin
et maintenant il fait des vidéos pour le
magasin pour vendre les produits voilà
ça a été félicité par kléber alors
justement fait mal et en plus je ris
c'est l'employé du moi pour nous nous a
offert des moments tellement drôle
regarde
rendre un petit
non pourquoi
mais non
on va les faire payer 25 29 août est
prêt
[Musique]
on a quand même à vous montrer le moment
où il va voir qu'en fait il était avec
son patron lui dire voilà c'est moins
pas trop je suis guéri mais regardez et
c'est un geek le patron comme toi ou c
c'est à paris il est fou bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
[Rires]
petit fan import
ont va venir ce qui ne fallait pas
louper et notamment cette image choc
c'est vendredi soir à 19h45 un français
âgé de 23 ans a posé volontairement une
femme belge de 55 ans sur les rails d'un
métro bruxellois en belgique cette scène
terrifiante l'appel tour des réseaux
sociaux et par chance le conducteur du
train a été exceptionnel il a réussi à
freiner à temps regardez et on a toutes
les infos sur cette affaire explique
gilbert b on va vous dire si ces offres
ou cissé on va voir on vous dira pour
garder cette marche une tentative de
meurtre s'est donc déroulée hier soir
dans le métro bruxellois un homme attend
le dernier moment pour pousser une femme
sur les rails le conducteur freine en
urgence juste à temps les caméras de
surveillance ont filmé toute la scène le
suspect sera entendu aujourd'hui par un
juge d'instruction qui décidera de son
maintien en détention
alors gilles est ce qu'ils se
connaissaient nom et se connaissaient
pas d'accord c'est un jeune français de
23 ans qui n'est pas domicilié en
belgique et même sa famille ne sait pas
ce qu'il faisait en belgique il a déjà
eu maille à partir avec la justice en
france et en belgique pour des vols et
usages de drogues ses côtés alors c'est
très fins et très possiblement le geste
d'un déséquilibré
mon sens où un expert psychiatrique a
tout de suite été désigné par le juge
d'instruction belge il est pour le
moment accusé de tentative de meurtre
ce serait plutôt un choix pris au hasard
comme ça un geste fou et y risque quand
même 20 ans de prison les belges allons
arrêter absolument mais un emballement
prison laval absolument donc même sa
famille dit on ne sait pas ce qui lui
est passé par la tête il n'avait pas de
masque c'est pour ça que les caméras de
surveillance selon ont permis de
l'arrêter une station plus loin très
rapidement sur la vidéo on voit un des
passants qui étaient là qui attendait le
métro qui fait un genre il remercie le
conducteur qui pour sa meule à la main à
son coeur en disant merci parce qu'il a
eu un mauvais la jeune femme alors ça va
elle a été hospitalisée la de la dame à
55 ans elle était hospitalisée elle est
entrée chez elle elle est très choquée
et pau ouais et pour revenir sur le
conducteur il a une fraction de seconde
il allait à 40 à l'heure une fraction de
seconde il a vu des gens faire des
signes et tout de suite il a actionné
l'arrêt d'urgence
a condamné en mai 2021 pour le meurtre
d'arthur noyer la cour d'assises de la
savoie a condamné l'ancien maître chien
à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle
aujourd'hui c'est pour une autre affaire
qui va être jugé
l'enlèvement et l'assassinât de la jeune
miley ce une histoire qui a bouleversé
tous les français alors que ce procès
débutera le 31 janvier les témoignages
autour de la personnalité de cet
individu se multiplient ce soir une de
ses ex compagnes a décidé de tout nous
révéler en exclusivité dans tpm p
merci au lit porri santoro d'être avec
nos journalistes d'investigation qui a
longuement enquêté sur nordahl le
landais qui a surtout longtemps
interviewé cette femme qui est sorti
avec le meurtrier alors cette dame elle
m'a contacté le 27 décembre oui voilà le
jour son 50e anniversaire d'accord et
textes que nordahl l'aurait largué ce
jour-là par téléphone d'accord et elle
l'aurait menacé de me contacter c'est à
dire que nordahl regarde tpm peu et il
n'a pas supporté mais les passages dans
l'émission d'accord selon elle je serai
le journaliste qu'il déteste le plus
parce que j'ai peut-être mis le doigt là
où ça fait mal à savoir le club de boxe
où il avait des accointances avec des
gens déjà nous en avait parlé la daf et
dossier ça c'est le grand sujet tabou
d'ailleurs de la sphère nordahl le
landais et donc elle l'aurait menacé
nordahl de me contacter ce qui l'aurait
mis dans un état de panique totale a
vraiment demandé de l'aider à s'évader
en fait ce qu'il voulait c'est que je
prenne des cours de pilotage
d'hélicoptères et de faire évader mais
quand il se rend centrale a chuté mais
ça donc je m'étais renseigné ça coûte 21
mille euros émile medimmune ce pas grave
tu feras un crédit s'est dite rencontre
le landais moi je veux pas d'une évasion
à la conjointe du spectaculaire un jeu
du redoine faïd habitants on vous l'a
fait écouter hier il comptait même allé
jusqu'à la chirurgie esthétique derrière
son évasion pour le but était de passer
par une une clinique chirurgicale
esthétique pardon en maghreb en tunisie
pour l'us de pas son bateau traverser la
méditerranée en bateau
- contrôler ensuite à de se faire opérer
la barbe
alors donc son projet c'était donc de
s'évader normal le landais donc c'est
son projet toujours là et ensuite de
faire la chirurgie esthétique etc c'est
justement la raison pour laquelle je
suis ici moi j'ai rien à gagner bien sûr
vous avez compris un peu le contexte
version moi j'ai évidemment refusé
d'écrire un livre à la gloire de cette
dame qui est un peu l'archétype de la
bourgeoise qui s'encanaille avec des bad
boys pour moi aller donner de l'argent
ce type jour ça scandaleux qu'il ait eu
le droit à un à un un parloir en unités
de vie familiale chaud ça scandaleux
qu'il ait pu avoir des rapports sexuels
continuer à jouir de privilèges je
trouve ça scandaleux et
il a donné à hauteur quand même et c'est
ce qu'elle m'explique qu'elle a dépensé
à peu près trente mille euros pour lui
elle aurait même participé selon ses
dires à ses frais d'avocats à hauteur de
13 mille euros elle lui a fait des
cadeaux j'en attendais il a pu donc
avoir avoir un palau en parlera avec
savoir familiale bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr il ya eu plus de temps dg des
chiffres c'est plus 280 parloir en tout
et il a même pu passer 24 heures avec
cette dame selon selon ce qu'elle me
raconte où il aurait eu des rapports
sexuels en way en toute décontraction
si c'est vrai j'ai entendu non pas du
tout de vous non mais je veux pas de
vous ça veut dire que il ay compris même
en prison des complicités des appuis à
saint-laurent l'été dernier j'ai pu
m'entretenir avec un détenu de saint
quentin fallavier qui m'a dit que là-bas
son surnom c'est nono le vip
il a une xbox 2 pc un frigo et
apparemment deux téléphones portables et
si vous voulez une exclu c'est que cette
dame mais il va falloir qu'elle assume
tout ce qu'elle m'a dit parce que vous
savez qu'elle a donné une interview dans
le dauphiné libéré après que je les
envoyer bouler d'accord dans cette
interview du dauphiné libéré le 14
janvier il n'y a rien de tout ce qu'elle
m'a raconté notamment le projet
d'évasion et c'est pour ça que je suis
là c'est parce que c'est beaucoup trop
grave pourrait presque passer sous
silence qui est selon l'ex compagne de
hollande et il aurait confirmé que
c'était un pédophile écoutez je lui ai
demandé s'ils étaient sexuellement
attiré par les enfants et il m'a répondu
que oui parce que sinon il n'aurait
jamais fait ce qu'il avait fait donc il
m'a dit forcément je prie
je lui ai demandé s'il avait pris du
plaisir à faire ce qu'ils avaient fait
m'a répondu que oui ça c'est très dur et
entend donc faire quoi faire quoi vu que
le qualificatif de viol n'a pas été
retenu c'est valérie vous avez pu
établir avec certitude que cette femme
est vraiment une ex compagne de d'ornano
du crime qu'elle ne connaît tous les
documents en ma possession et recouper
vous a permis de réussir que c'est pas
une blague à fabuler qui j'ai tous les
documents en ma possession lui les
permis de visite notamment une
attestation de sa part qui s'engagent à
me certifier que tout ça est authentique
sa carte d'identité j'ai absolument tout
boli est d'ailleurs j'ai donné tous les
audio à la police évidemment que j'ai
déjà prévenu la police est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez peur c'est vers
vous avez reçu de nombreuses menaces est
ce que vous avez pris oui ah oui il
m'arrive d'être idiot ceux du sud
notamment puis mes passages ici qui ont
excité avec le monde ouais ouais mais je
devais le faire ça je pouvais pas le
laisser passer sinon que ça aurait fait
de moi un complice si j'avais pas parler
de tout ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]